- Yeah!
There it is.
- You drink enough of that,
everything's gonna be great again.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- So BuzzFeed apparently spent $200
on this discontinued Trump vodka
so that we could drink it today.
- This?
(gasping in disbelief)
- You spent $200 on Trump vodka?
(peaceful instrumental music)
- I didn't know Trump had a vodka.
- I guess he kind of looks
like he just took a shot.
- This is like his skin color.
(laughing)
- The world's finest...
- "Produced and bottled by..."
What is it?
"The Netherlands?"
That's not America.
- It's probably gonna taste like misogyny.
- Inequality.
- This vodka is going to
taste like self tanner.
- Pray for me.
- [Man] L'Chaim!
- Wait, it's a cork.
- Ooo!
(chuckling)
- Do I have to do all that?
That was a lot.
- Uh oh!
- There you go.
- [Man Two] Yeah?
- I can do that.
(clinking glasses together)
- Okay, let's go.
(exclaiming in disgust)
- [Both] Cheers!
- I'm so afraid.
- That is surprisingly good.
- Ooo, ooo, that burns like a UTI.
- Trump Vodka, putting
the T back into UTI.
(laughing)
- It tastes like a mix in
between a expensive vodka
and a cheap vodka.
Nah.
- It's good, it's not $200 good.
- I would pay not to drink this.
- This may be hard to believe
but I have actually had worse
vodka than this in my life.
- I would do another shot of this,
I hate to say.
(clinking glasses together)
- Just for you internet.
- Ahhh!
- Oh, we need to build a wall around this.
So it doesn't hurt anybody ever again.